[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory I
think it goes without saying that 2023
was a big and very much needed year for
Harry Potter fans in February the long
awaited and massively popular Hogwarts
Legacy was released an immersive open
world action RPG set in the same Whiting
world as the Harry Potter books and just
a few months later word spread of a
decade long Harry Potter series expected
to premiere on HBO each season will be
authentic to the original books and
bring Harry Potter and these incredible
Adventures to new audiences around the
world while the Original Classic and
beloved films will remain at the core of
the franchise and available to watch
globally but perhaps the best part of
all of this is just how successful
hogwart's Legacy grew to be B by the
time hogwart's Legacy was released Harry
Potter was in need of revitalization
more than ever and had the game flopped
well I don't even want to think about it
and we really don't have to because as
it turns out hogwart's Legacy was the
top selling game of 2023 across all
platforms and all genres beating out
Call of Duty Madden Zelda Diablo and
more gone are the days of Harry Potter
games tanking and being swept under the
rug
it's time to usher in a new era of
Wizarding World Excellence since the
game's release over 22 million copies
have been sold amounting to over 707
million hours played 8819 million
potions poured 1.3 billion plants
plucked 593 million beasts saved and 5
billion evil wizards thwarted and as it
turns out they're not done it's only
been a year and they've already got new
and exciting updates in the pipeline on
January 26th the official Hogwarts
Legacy Twitter released the following
statement as we near the 1-year
anniversary of Hogwarts Legacy we wanted
to let our community know that the
Hogwarts Legacy PlayStation exclusive
content will be available on other
platforms later this summer along with
additional updates and features for the
game stay tuned in the coming months for
more details on what's coming to
Hogwarts Legacy this year while the
Tweet doesn't provide a clear outline of
what the upcoming content is it does
mention that current PlayStation
exclusive offerings in Hogwarts Legacy
including the Haunted Hogs me shop Quest
and the exclusive Felix felic potion
recipe which was a bonus for PlayStation
pre-orders The Haunted Hogs me Quest
immerses players in an eerie storyline
where they acquire an old decrepit shop
from the enigmatic Cassandra Mason only
to discover that the premises are
haunted by a mischievous Poltergeist
the poist traps players in a chilling
maze filled with perplexing optical
illusions making it one of the most
spine tingling and exquisitely designed
missions within Hogwarts Legacy it was
disheartening for many players that this
mission was limited to select platforms
but the recent announcement suggest that
this exclusivity is about to change some
fans were a little disappointed by the
announcement purely because they
expected these PlayStation exclusive
offerings to be dropped in February at
the one-year mark But at least now we
know that they're on the way excitement
has been ignited among players by the
announcement stemming not only from the
anticipation of additional updates and
features but also from a desire for
broader accessibility fans are
expressing hope that the new content
will bring enhancements such as photo
mode New Game Plus functionality the
inclusion of quidditch and the
possibility of a substantial expansion
to the game's narrative considering
Hogwarts legacies a sounding sales
figures of 22 million copies marking it
as the year's bestselling game worldwide
it is highly surprising that the
prospect of more content is met with
enthusiasm the tremendous demand for
additional magical adventures is
apparent among eag players and i' wag of
this update is just the first of many in
the years to come but now that we've
established mystery updates on the way
in the form of additional features and
updates my next question is what are
these features here's what I want to see
quiddit the biggest lost opportunity of
Hogwarts Legacy is the extremely
apparent lack of quiddit there's a
quidditch pitch we can fly broom and the
game is an integral part of Harry Potter
law since hogwart's Legacy has inspired
a new generation of Harry Potter fans
that may or may not know the intricacies
of quiddit let me Briefly summarize
quidditch is a team sport played by
witches and wizards on broomsticks and
involves four balls a quaffer two
bludgers and a golden snitch a game of
quidditch is played with seven players
on each team and each player has a
specific position and role the objective
of the game is to score points by
throwing the quaffle through one of the
opposing team's three Hoops while
simultaneously Defending Your Own team's
hoops from the other team the two
bludgers are used to disrupt the players
and throw them off course the game ends
when the golden snitch a small fast
moving ball with wings is caught by one
of the players the team that catches the
snitch earns 150 points and ends the
game given that there's a quiditch pitch
already developed on the Hogs grounds
this seems like an obvious and
inevitable piece of DLC try wizard
tournament the try Wiz a tournament is a
magical competition held between three
Wizarding schools Hogwart School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry bobor Academy of
magic and durmstrang Institute in this
tournament One champion is chosen to
represent each school and compete in
three dangerous tasks but the winner
receiving a grand prize these tasks test
the skills bravery and intelligence of
the chosen champions from each School
the tasks are kept secret until the day
of the tournament and the winner is
awarded the Triwizard cup and eternal
glory given that Hogwarts is a
participant in the fabled tri wizard
tournament it seems obvious that the tri
wizard tournament would be included as
DLC the problem with this well it did
break Cannon the reason I say that this
is because the tri was a tournament was
discontinued after
1792 taking a 200-year Hiatus before
being resurrected in
1994 a tri was a tournament in 1890 just
wouldn't make sense and given that the
game has done such a good job of
preserving Cannon so far I'm not
completely convinced that this will
become available other schools the
possibility for Hogwarts Legacy
developers to include other schools
seems to me fairly likely I say this
because other schools are mentioned in
the game and developers would be able to
capitalize on an area of law where it
would be much harder to contradict Canon
we don't know too much about the other
Wizarding schools and so this sort of
DLC would give them a lot of freedom and
when I say other schools I am of course
referring to the long list of other
Wizarding schools across the globe not
just the ones from the tri wizard
tournament these schools include iloni
North America Muto cororo Japan Castello
bruu Brazil wagadu Africa durmstrang
northern Europe Bator France and kovor
Russia if you want more info on these
schools then check out my video the
history of every Magic School in The
Wizarding World all 11 Harry Potter
explained bigger World The Wizarding
World of Harry Potter is vast and so I'd
very much like them to expand the
explorable areas if it was mentioned or
shown in the books and or films then I'd
like the ability to go there little
hangleton privet Drive the ministry of
magic these are all places I'd like to
be able to openly explore the rest in
addition to the above larger pieces of
DLC I'd also like to see the following
smaller things implemented either
through DLC or patches these things
include subsequent school years M 67
interactive NPCs craftable polyu potion
higher max levels more talents more side
companion quests consequences for using
dark magic with sitting law implemented
consequences for being underage and
entering the Forbidden Forest the
ability to become an animus Time Turner
time manipulation enhanced morality
system more spell variety Wizarding
careers and the ability to cast a
Patronis I'd also like ability to sit
down and relax in various locations
including common rooms customization
options for personal rooms in the common
rooms similar to the room of requirement
New Game Plus feature to be added
allowing players to replay the game with
added challenges or benefits ability to
change the time of year providing the
option to select desired weather
conditions introduction of companions
expanded customization options such as
more hairstyles faces and body types
enhanced interactions within the common
room including the ability to sleep talk
to other students store equipment play
wizard chess and incentivize spending
time as a student with consequences for
nighttime escapades of course bearing
all of the above pieces of potential DLC
in mind I think I can safely say that
among all potential new features
multiplayer would probably have the
biggest impact multiplayer mods are in
development by independent developers
but as of now pkey game/ Avalanche
software have not mentioned anything at
the end of the day it's still early days
for Hogwarts Legacy and given the
massive popularity of the game thus far
I'm sure the possibility of DLC is
extremely high squel given the
commercial success of Hogwarts Legacy
and its relative infancy I don't think
fans should expect any sort of a sequel
anytime soon particularly if we consider
how much time and effort and delays went
into the release of the first game
however I'd be more than willing to bet
that a good portion of the above
mentioned features will be rolled out in
the years to come and that's it for this
video what do you want to see let me
know down in the comment section below
also I've stopped streaming the game but
let me know if you'd be interested in
future streams until next time remember
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to
live